it turns out working for amazon is a
highly dangerous job
much more than working for its big box
competitors according to a report from
the strategic organizing center there
were over 27 000 recorded injuries to
amazon employees in 2020 alone
in other words for every 100 employees
there were nearly six serious injuries
now current and former amazon employees
are speaking up including gabe kaminsky
who says working for amazon was an
alienating experience
and its employees are treated like
robots joining me now is gabe kaminsky a
former amazon employee and writer at the
federalist along with congressman ro
khanna
whose congressional district includes
silicon valley thank you both
for coming on thanks for having me
uh gabe i want to start with you just
tell us a little bit about what was
alienating
about working for amazon
yeah so i was an amazon prime shopper at
a whole foods grocery store
you know i essentially showed up to
orientation expecting
at least some some degree of uh you know
maybe a supervisor or someone to really
walk me through
sort of you know a very uh basic
position which entails uh
packing groceries that delivery uh
drivers would eventually pick up
um and essentially i got to uh
orientation and i was
there was really um no uh no one to walk
me through the experience you know it
was sort of the entire job is through a
work phone
um and it was really a glimpse into the
job there was really no one to walk us
through
how we would do the position you know
congressman khanna one of the things
that i think
we talk about a lot when it comes to
amazon on both sides of the political
aisle is
is its enormous power and in terms of
its its market impact
during the pandemic though we also have
seen it become one of the places that
really thrived
and so one of the questions that i have
for you is isn't aren't there other
negative outcomes that we have going on
today with
a lot of these entities that are frankly
despite their propaganda pushing out
small businesses preventing them from
being able to have success and the like
well i think we are seeing a great
divergence i mean you have in my
district
a market cap of 10 trillion dollars
and a lot of small businesses a lot of
left behind communities
aren't participating in modern wealth
generation and then i thought gabe wrote
a very
inspiring piece where workers have
basically become
accessories to robots i'm all for
technological advance that's going to
lead to productivity where that's going
to
help benefit the american people but we
should not use
technology as a tool to grab power
away from workers to management and
dehumanize the workplace
and we need regulations that would
prevent
companies from doing that well one of
the things that i think you experienced
gabe
was basically just the the atomization
effect of
working at amazon that i think it often
escapes the debate
there are negative consequences for that
in terms of and
just an ability to relate to each other
and as
human beings within a workplace aren't
there
yeah ben i think people you know they
they like to be with one another i think
you know the workplace there's no secret
that a job the point of a job is
certainly to get paid but i think there
are other aspects of a job such as
you know building a community within an
area and really
building those relationships with your
supervisor with your fellow colleagues
and certainly places you know with this
big business they come into these
communities
and they sort of just break up and don't
allow people
in these areas to really uh build those
relationships with people
uh you know in those areas congressman
quickly i
i feel like one of the other elements of
this that we have to appreciate
is that there doesn't seem to be one
easy answer on this
people want the convenience of amazon
they want the ability to have things
show up within a day or two
at the same time there's can be some
negative consequences that come with it
that i feel like we don't really weigh
in our country today
i think you're absolutely right and this
is why we need nuance policies i mean
it's great that there are rural
communities of underserved communities
that now can have
access to products that they may never
have had so
we don't want to wholesale reject the
innovation
economy and the fact that we are having
conversations over
facetime or skype in some cases we're
creating new communities
but we have to make sure that workers
aren't exploited
that workers still have the opportunity
to organize and the congress has been
asleep i mean really we need
bipartisan uh smart thoughtful
regulation that doesn't hurt innovation
i think gabe's peace makes a real
contribution to getting there
congressman and gabe thank you so much
for taking the time to join me tonight
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else